for more on the vaccine and the increase
on coronavirus cases we're joined now by
cbs news medical contributor
dr david agus dr agus let's start with
this idea rise of cases around 10
in more than 20 states do we know why
welcome back dana um you know it's it's
young people
um it's young people it's young people
it's young people i think the numbers
are actually underestimated young people
are much more likely to be asymptomatic
and they're not being tested as much in
the south we have dramatically lower
testing
than we did before we're seeing increase
in er
visits of younger individuals under the
age of 60
and you know it's a testament the
vaccine is working older individuals are
vaccinated
they wear our canary in a coal mine of
hey they're they're symptomatic let them
get tested
and so we're seeing a change here and
the change is
you know becoming because we're lowering
the guidelines people are able to go out
now without mass
in certain areas people have more
ability to spread the virus and with
these newer strains that are
much more infectious it is really scary
so the good news is that 30 percent of
the population has gotten the vaccine at
least one shot
so two questions for you what now and
how soon before you come back in studio
i'm there i mean so 3.975 million
vaccines yesterday almost 4 million
vaccines so
we are doing well rolling out the
vaccines so what it means is if you're
vaccinated you can get together with
other
vaccinated individuals in small groups
or with
one pod that is not vaccinated you just
saw the travel restrictions coming down
and those are big
believe me i want to be in the studio
i've asked to come in this studio and i
am ready to come in the studio i will be
on a plane
as soon and now i'm not able to go on a
plane as soon as cbs which is always a
little bit slow on the restrictions says
come back
no not at all safety uh we just got to
pull him out of sunny southern
california
the doctor is refusing to leave on
on a serious note though doctor so um
pfizer released these results this week
as you know
from the trial involving kids 12 and
over so what do we know so far about
whether kids are protected from either
the pfizer or moderna or johnson and
johnson
and when can families anticipate that
kids will be able to get fully
vaccinated
you know i think every parent is saying
not soon enough so right now
pfizer is 16 and older the modern and j
j are 18 and older
the data came out 12 to 16 and it was
remarkably safe
it showed that even a small number of
cases blocked uh
infection 100 percent for being
symptomatic so it works
kids can have immunity to the vaccine
that was a big step
now six months and older as dr falchi
alluded to he said by the end of the
year but my gut is it happens much
sooner
i think the trials are ongoing now and
the data are looking very encouraging
the vaccine will be safe in children
and they will get immunity from the
vaccine and we're going
to have to vaccinate kids 25 percent of
the u.s population
is below the age of 21 years of age so
we have to do it and i hope it happens
soon soon soon
i just logged on to google flights and
booked something
next friday doctor we'll see we'll see
if that holds next week
we're busting you out of it we're we're
kidding of course we want you to be safe
and everybody so doctor thank you very
much
thank you